il
manger
le kayamb est un instrument de musique
utilisée dans les mascareignes pour
jouer le séga et le maloya c'est un
instrument de percussion idiophones
entendez par là un instrument dont le
son est produit par le matériau d'un
instrument lui même on le décrit comme
un hochet en forme de radeaux c'est un
idiot phone parce coumans
l'histoire du kayamb est intimement liée
à celle du maloya il sera arrivé avec
les premiers esclaves à la réunion c'est
un instrument qui incarne l'âme de la
musique réunionnaise à lui seul il
résume toute l'histoire de l'île
l'héritage des esclaves des plantations
de canne à sucre ce sont eux qui ont
construit les premiers kayamb à la
réunion avec ce qu'ils trouvaient dans
les champs du doigt des graines et des
tiges de fleurs de cannes
nous sommes dans les eaux de trois
bassins jean noël revient de sa
cueillette de fleurs de canne à sucre
élément essentiel à la fabrication du
kayamb dans une cabane en bois sous tôle
au fond de sa cour il fabrique des
clients de toutes tailles et cela dure
depuis 22 ans
danyel waro après les films à viry
maintien grâce à
la can les instruments musique là
les commentaires peu intéressants il
gagne pas de grand sault surveiller mais
gagne émeutiers
et le camion l'a effectivement mener
loin
le maloya devenu patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco jean-noël exporte son
savoir-faire et participe à des
expositions
ça va
et on est trop pas
aller à lyon
un produit dont il est fier de
transmettre le principe de fabrication
en animant des ateliers chez lui ou
ailleurs mais attention de bien faire
les choses dans les règles de l'art ne
gagne pas ça pour moindre parce que ça
n'a pas un accès gaza est pas maître mot
et belhadji satin l'un pour saler les
les bacs tout le monde mais quand même
il dissertait gagne pas fait quand tu
fais pas ça parce que pour les autres
personnes greffées à savoir faire
reconnu parmi les plus grands artistes
locaux qui savent vers qui se tourner
pour avoir un bon client donc devenir
des héros de sa part aux dahlias tous
demandent musicien a besoin d'un
instrument là il connaît ça me les héros
de sa part ou d'ailleurs
car la calamité
minichaîne il est après sa nourrice
paulo les artères de l'est pour les
trois autres en projet la capite
une passion et un savoir faire dont les
amateurs et passionnés de musique locale
pour bénéficier tant que jean-noël vivre
à
temps